des prisons surpeuplées donc en raison
notamment de la présence des prévenus ce
sont ces personnes qui sont incarcérés
et qui sont en attente d'un jugement je
reçois mario vacheret à les
criminologues spécialiste de la question
dans son n va serait enfin madame
galipeau ya un chiffre dans le reportage
jean michel qui est vraiment sursauter
c'est le 55 % non plus de la moitié des
gens qui sont incarcérés dans les
prisons provinciales sont en fait des
gens qui sont en attente de procès dont
qui sont présumées innocentes
c'est énorme oui tout à fait c'est un
chiffre que gigantesque qui interpelle
beaucoup parce que là c'est ce qu'on a
c'est les données un jour donné donc
plus de la moitié de la population mais
si on regarde le nombre de personnes qui
rentrent sur une année c'est encore plus
important
donc ça met une pression sur le système
oui oui ça pose beaucoup de questions ça
met une pression sur le système bon dans
le reportage on a parlé de surpopulation
carcérale
mais c'est aussi un enjeu derrière ça ou
moi je vois une espèce de volonté de
punir une volonté de montrer à la
population qu'on incarcère qu'on est
capable de réagir par rapport à la
criminalité alors qu'on s'adresse à un
groupe qui finalement n'est pas encore
reconnue coupable vous l'avez dit
majoritairement ce sont des gens qui
sont là pour des petits délits souvent
des bris de probation donc des gens qui
ont été condamnés à une ordonnance de
probation avec certaines conditions qui
n'ont pas respecté leurs conditions pas
le droit de boire de l'alcool par
exemple puis on les a sortis dans les a
pris à la sortie d'un bar à ce moment là
ils sont incarcérés c'est la majorité ce
qui pose des questions c'est pas des
délits violents c'est pas des cas
majeurs et l'autre profil qui pose aussi
question c'est beaucoup sont se
retrouvent détenus de façon presque
systématique simplement à cause du
délits qu'ils ont commis
parce que c'est un délit soumis à une
peine minimale obligatoire aujourd'hui
donc c'est à eux de prouver qu'ils ne
l'ont pas commis sinon ils sont
incarcérés automatiquement durant les
procédures et 606 nombreux danser dans
ses prisons c'est qu'autrefois il aurait
été libéré sous conditions c'est ça où
il a pu être patients et à payer un
resserrement des
des législations qui font que ces gens
là sont beaucoup plus systématiquement
incarcéré alors que normalement ils
devraient se retrouver à l'extérieur
c'est une tendance qu'on retrouve
partout en occident mais qui est quand
même encore plus remarquable chez nous
on n'est pas très heureux de faire les
frais de ce genre de deux chiffres qui
dénonce conséquences sur sur les détenus
sont les droits des détenus
oui il ya des conséquences à plusieurs
niveaux dont la présomption d'innocence
bien sûr parce que la personne elle est
incarcérée alors qu'elle n'est pas
encore reconnue coupable mais aussi le
droit à un procès juste et équitable
faut pas oublier que c'est normalement
une mesure de dernier recours on doit
l'utiliser de façon parcimonieuse qui
n'est pas ce qu'on fait et en
incarcérant durant les procédures la
personne un procès - juste parce que son
avocat a plus de mal à l'aider à
préparer sa défense
la personne est isolée exclue
socialement elle perd ses garanties
sociales elle va souvent perdre son
emploi éventuellement perdre son
logement
si l'incarcération dure longtemps donc
elle va au moment de son procès établir
- une moins bonne insertion sociale donc
risqué plus d'être condamnée et adélie
égal on s'est rendu compte à travers les
études que quelqu'un qui était incarcéré
durant les procédures étaient plus
souvent condamné à une peine
d'incarcération et que celles ci étaient
plus lourdes que pour un même délit
quelqu'un qui était resté libérée
pendant les procédures et tout ça s'est
accentué depuis quelques années en fait
c'est de pousser de plus en plus marqué
oui depuis
les années 2000 c'est sûr que c'est une
tendance de fond mais qu'on constate
encore plus aujourd'hui qui montre
vraiment cette idée qu'on a aujourd'hui
où on veut montrer à la population qu'on
est capable de punir donc c'est un peu
facile
ce sont des gens ils commettent un délit
ils sont arrêtés immédiatement c'est
souvent à ce moment là cia médiatisation
qu'on va en parler
donc on montera la population regarde et
on est actif ont ont fait du populisme
pénal on montre à la population qu'on
est un bon gouvernement qu'on est
capable de bien s'occuper de la
criminalité puisque on incarcère ces
gens là alors que ce sont pas des gens
qui mettent en danger la société pour
une grande partie d'entre eux et donc
quelle est la solution comment on fait
pour pour pour améliorer cette situation
là parce que c'est une véritable crise
dans nos prisons c'est un problème qui
pour moi pourrait être résolu beaucoup
par tous les programmes de réinsertion
sociale programme dans la communauté
intervention dans la communauté sion on
enlève la minorité effectivement de
personnes qu'il faut arrêter qui ont un
agir violents ou dangereux la majorité
de ces gens là pour être des gens qui
restent dans la société et qui ont dit
des contraintes au niveau de la société
mais aussi des programmes
on va voir dans cette direction là
disent pas du tout pas du tout ça ça
prend des investissements dans la
communauté or aujourd'hui ont désinvesti
partout et encore plus dans les
infrastructures d'insertion sociale et
de réinsertion sociale
merci beaucoup ça va mieux en parler ce
soir